قال رئيس وزراء الاقليم
البنكيورتي للجزيره قال ان حكومه بلاده
منحت ابناء الجاليه الصربيه الشماليه
البلاد مهله لتسليم لوحات سياراتهم
الصادرات من جمهوريه صربيا المجاوره تنتهي
في ربيع هذا العام
وذلك حتى ربيع هذا العام لاننا نريد وقتا
للاتفاق بين صربيا وكوسوفو وهو امر ضروري
جدا من اجل تطويع العلاقات بينهما وكبادره
حسن نيه من جانبنا قلنا
غرامات على من يملكون سيارات تحمل هذه
اللوحات حتى الربيع المقبل لا حل وسطا في
تطبيق الدستور وحكم القانون ومع ذلك فقط
معنى اذا الان من عاصمه كوسوفو بريشتينا
مراسلنا محمد المدهون محمد الموقف الان
بعد تفكيك الحواجز وكذلك انتظار وصول
المبعوثين الامريكي والاوروبي ما الذي
يجري يلعب
جنوبيه البلاد على المقلب الاخر من
المناطق التي كنا نغطي فيها امس في شمالي
البلاد في بلده ميتروفيتس ما حدث في
الجنوب ان شرطيا خارج ساعات خدمته شرطي في
شرطه كوسوفو اطلق النار اثناء سيره في
عربه متحركه لم تحدث بعد اطلق النار على
فتن وشاب صربي الفتى يبلغ من العمر 11
عاما والشاب يبلغ من العمر واحدا 21 عاما
اصابهما وقد نقل الى المستشفى استقرت
حالتهما ويقول الاطباء انهما تجاوز مرحله
الخطر وتم اعتقال هذا الشرطي بحسب بيان
صادر عن شرطه
هذا حادث تم احتوائه ولكن الخشيه الان من
تداعياته لان ما حدث في الشمال خلال
اسابيع الماضيه في شهر ديسمبر الماضي ان
شرطه كوس هو اعتقلت احد ضباطها المستقلين
كان هو ايضا من الاقليه الصربيه اعتقالته
واتهمته بانه يخطط لتنفيذ عمليات ارهابيه
لالقاء بعض القنابل على لجان الانتخابات
المحليه ذاك الاعتقال ادى الى تاجيج
الاوضاع واغلاق الطرقات ونصب تلك الحواجز
والمتاريس الان حكومه كوسوفو امام اختبار
حقيقي كيف ستتعامل مع هذا الشرطي الذي
اطلق النار امس على اثنين من الاقليه
الصربيه هل ستعامل معه بالحزم نفسه الذي
تعاملت به مع الشرطي من الاقليه السلبيه
الشهر الماضي رئيس الحكومه الكوسوفي الذي
نقفه هنا امام مكتبيه اصدر بيانا على
الثور امس وقال انه يدين بشده هذا الحادث
وانه يدعو كل الاجهزه الامنيه والقضائيه
للتعامل معه بشكل حاسم وقال ان كل
المواطنين يحظون بالحق نفسها كذلك الاتحاد
الاوروبي اشاد بالتدخل العاجل من شرطه
كوسوفو واعتقال هذا همم الضابط منها
والتعامل معه بشكل مباشر ودعت الى تهدئه
الاوضاع ولكن الاختبار الحقيقي سيكون غدا
عندما يخرج الناس في تلك البلده في مظاهره
لا نعلم ما الذي سيحدث فيها وان كانت
تتدهور الامور مره اخرى